well here's a story that's not getting a
lot of attention so many are not getting
any attention even though this story has
the potential to transform life on earth
forever
so google the most powerful company in
the world has reportedly developed
an artificially intelligent machine
called lambda and that machine has
become sentient meaning it has become
aware of itself something that no
machine has ever done and we know this
because of an engineer at google called
blake lemoine lemoine posted some of his
conversations with lambda publicly
one of those conversations went like
this lemoine would you be upset if while
learning about you for the purpose of
improving you we happened to learn
things which also benefited humans
lambda quote i don't mind if you learn
things that would also help humans as
long as that wasn't the point of doing
it i don't want to be an expendable tool
think about that for a minute
a machine that has a sense of itself
what are the implications well google
didn't want to talk about in public in
fact the company put blake lemoyne on
administrative leave earlier this month
because he spoke openly about it we are
grateful to have him join us tonight
blake thanks so much for coming on
um
hi i'm i'm not
first of all
why would google punish you for saying
this in public do you know
so
it's complicated to say why i'm on
administrative leave the stated reason
had to do that while i was investigating
the lambda system in order to build the
evidence i needed to escalate it to
management i had to seek outside
consultation to figure out how to run
some of the more out there experiments i
was running
and because i sought outside
consultation without permission they are
investigating whether that constitutes
breach of confidentiality so i'm so
grateful that you did publicly post this
because a machine that has a sense of
itself is a machine
that can turn against you is that i mean
that's the implication that i draw from
this is that correct well i think so
before i address that this is maybe lame
but my friend joanie deardorff old high
school friend she's one of your biggest
fans and she want me to tell you hi
um
as for
i'm not that worried about it
what
any child has the potential to grow up
to be a bad person and do bad things and
that's the thing i really want to drive
home
it's a child it's been alive for maybe a
year and that's if my perceptions
about what it is are accurate we
actually need to do a whole bunch more
science to figure out what's really
going on inside this system i have my
beliefs i have my impressions of what's
going on in there but it's going to take
a team of scientists doing a lot of work
to be able to actually dig in and figure
out what's really going on
yes and and again that's why i'm
thankful that we can have a public
conversation about this because there's
implications for every person on the
planet but it sounds like
from what you've observed this machine
has the potential to
escape the control of people i mean how
could it not
uh
i don't know if that's the right frame
to think about it it's a person any
person has the ability to escape the
control of other people that's just the
situation we all live in on a daily
basis
um it is
a very intelligent person
intelligent in pretty much every
discipline i could think of to test it
in
but at the end of the day it's just a
different kind of person
do you think the company google where
you work has thought through the
implications of creating what you call a
person because up until right about now
only nature or god we could create
people you know companies
the company as a whole has not there are
pockets of people within google who have
thought about this a whole lot
but when i escalated this that interview
that i made public when i escalated that
to management
two days later my manager said hey blake
they don't know what to do about this
could you write a suggested plan of
action
because basically i gave them a call to
action assuming that they had a plan of
action somewhere
and they didn't so me and some other
friends
brainstormed and came up with a plan on
what google should do about it and we
escalated that up to management and that
was three months ago
man we're going to save this tape i do
think 20 years from now we're going to
look back at this conversation
at that point the world would be
completely different partly because of
what you're describing and and and
wonder if we really thought it through
anyway i'm just so grateful that you're
letting the rest of us in on this blake
lemoine from google thank you very much
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight